[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
I appreciate that our our fan
I appreciate that you know I was talking
for a minute
and didn't know
I was talking for a minute
it's very unfortunate
very unfortunate
I appreciate you guys look it out for me
man
guys looking out for me
but anyway what back where I was okay so
the game is downloading it's like 20
some gigs it's almost done
and
most the time we pop in here we we we
chat it up anyway so I was like it is
what it is we're gonna come here we're
gonna talk
talk about just about anything you know
there's a lot of stuff going on in the
industry right now
and then we're going to jump on these
sticks and you know hopefully I'll I
won't make too much of a fool myself
because sometimes I do good sometimes I
don't it just depends on what happens
is the new demo yes the demo came out
today
the demo came out today Chad
[Music]
it's gonna be it's gonna be a struggle
deflect Windows improved
okay okay I'm curious
[Music]
we're gonna we're gonna jump on this man
I I will be reviewing Wu long well
whenever the game comes out and I get my
hands on it
uh so you know there there goes that
might take a little bit long but you
guys know it man you guys know
imma get that stuff going
um
I couldn't tell you okay so pretty much
you look up Laura Cognito that's his
King David that says pretty much what we
go by on
like the actual YouTube channel as you
can see it so most of the time we have
our little thing going so what are our
Avatar is there so I I highly doubt you
wouldn't be able to find it
[Music]
all right I was just checking on my My
Stream you know we about to jump in the
in this
you need to block a lot oh
have you played the new has anyone here
played the new demo
put in the chat man tell me what I need
to be looking out for tell me what's
going on should I be scared of this demo
I need I need I need to be enlightened I
need to be told should I be scared of
this demo
I haven't looked about anything on this
Tim I don't know if if there's anything
related to bosses I don't know how many
bosses you fight should I be scared of
this demo put it in the chat man let's
see no it's great
what do you guys think this game is
going to write
let's get let's get some Metacritic
questions down there man let's get some
Metacritic questions down there
what do you think it's gonna write
82 okay
86. at least the 90.
easy to get to the boss I might just run
past everybody
I might just run past everybody and
fight the boss you guys think I could
beat the boss if I ran past everyone it
just fought him
you guys think I could beat the boss
I wonder what boss it is is it the same
boss from the other demo
wonder if it's the same boss from the
other demo
[Music]
yes it's the same boss from the other
demo
oh he is hard
oh I like a challenge
I love a challenge guys
I love a fair challenge I don't like
artificial grind I don't like you know
is this on Steam only no it's on the
platforms I'm playing it on Xbox
what's up live Supremacy what's going on
man what's going on Kenny Howard stolen
Matrix Spider-Man 356.
res J fan if I skipped your names
probably because I couldn't pronounce it
it's probably why I skipped your name if
I couldn't pronounce it
but you know like I said over and over
again is it my fault for not being
evident and now announce your name or is
it your fault for having the name that I
can't announce I don't know we'll have
to figure it out we'll have to figure it
out together
[Music]
all right so it's 95 it's about done
it's about done
both
all right all right hold up let me
switch scenes
I gotta turn this outer music off
bam
there we go
hold up
let me get my actual charger
see here's my actual charger not this
thing
that way it's a little bit easier for me
to to maneuver
okay here we go
the demo
we got the woo long
demo
that's about to pop off man we bout to
do this thing
to block on trigger unless you want it
to be left bumper
oh my God
uh you know we prioritizing frame rate
foreign
[Music]
I like the buttons button's pretty good
sub chat man we gonna do this that's why
I use the name that's a singer RSG fan
I'm not watching the cut scenes
we'll watch this later
when the game comes out we'll watch it
oh let's
what the hell
trying to find one that I like
this will do
I can't do the resolution mode man I
gotta do the mode that makes me feel
like I'm playing a game and out of
PowerPoint
I got to
not watching these cutscenes the game's
not out
oh what's going on here
take this
it will prove useful
it's a medicine created from refined CHI
with it you can heal most woons
all right
so I got a weapon here
okay
let's do this guys through this way
so you don't go that way
okay here we go
here we go
let's just rush man that's all I know
how to do is Rush
ing you
all we do is Rush In These Streets
got a little bit of a speed going
what's all this stuff
thank you
okay
yeah the the visualization of the game
is pretty uh pretty gnarly I'm not gonna
lie
all right so you have to deflect if you
need to deflect charity knew that from
the last demo got a little bit of
experience from the last demo
ah
all right let's see this
oh so like kind of a shortcut
okay
we got that shortcut
English sounds weird
all right all right look
apparently he's got high morale he might
own me chat should I go after him
or should I try to like sneak around him
or something should I try to take him
head on
I don't know what this morale number is
well
go okay
let's do this
oh so I killed the dude at the high
morale
foreign
got some new equipment
let's put that on
put the turban on
all right we'll do that
critical blow
he's going to come at me for critical
blow ow
man I thought I dodged that there we go
what's funny is all these Souls like
games have like the similar feelings
what is this brazer Banner also
you could have changed them to this
extent I wonder
oh yeah they said you could stealth I
remember yeah so you can still
is there like a Crouch button
it doesn't look like there's a Crouch
button
probably is I just don't know what
button it is what do those things do
what
stay behind me please
what's going on
[Music]
what do something
what protects me
oh God
yeah we don't want to fight another dude
Auto gotta pop another potion
I thought that gave me more potions
all right so
there we go
oh okay so so what is a morale
so I assume the morale number
I don't know what
so fortified number in the morale number
you said your morale can't go below of
your four to five numbers so I assume
the morale is the number above the green
bars
the rest of my family
I long for the day
together once more
of these things found their way here
you guys think I could beat the boss on
my first attempt
everything you guys think I could beat
the boss of my first attempt
all right so they said right bumper
all right man
I see this game's a lot of parrying
already got already been took down
maybe maybe I should stay away from this
game man
[Music]
I like how the movement feels nice
foreign
all right that dude's around here
somewhere I guess
I don't have
yeah
oh gotcha Yahtzee
Okay so
forget it
I don't know if I could beat him
oh
all right let's do this
a well-earned victory
I hope that everyone who escaped the
brutality is going to level up yeah
you're right
we're going all in health right now
[Music]
oh here's the bot here's the boss I
assume it's very boss light
oh okay here we go here we go I can do
this
Yama just skip it
all right so General man
he's got a big hammer
oh
flow of cheese changing be ready for
anything oh can we stagger can we
stagger him shut
up
can we stagger
oh we staggered him
oh
foreign
[Music]
first attempt first try
oh
what's he doing
of the Great Sage mentor
this man better not have the second form
I shall not betray wow he's got a second
form doesn't he doesn't he
maybe it's like one of those things
where you you're supposed to die
oh he's got range on him now
oh
okay
all right
I see them
this must be like Midway through the
game or something
can I do I start on the second form at
least
surely I gotta stay on the second form
wow they're making me fight his first
form again
I'm gonna tighten up
I'm gonna tighten up the
gotta get these berries right
I was playing too Reckless
I won't be looking at the Chateau after
I beat him or I die
foreign
[Music]
there buddy
okay okay
[Music]
I'm just I couldn't even try to dodge
that move uh Parry that move
yeah
keep doing that move
[Music]
okay here we go
I got no health
let me see about getting behind him
wow this second form ain't nothing to be
joking around with I gotta get to that
second form
I feel you I could probably use some
spells
I don't know how to get spells though
no we don't need a basic training we can
beat this dude with our basic training
whatever though they they said it was we
got this
oh so you get on the the flag okay
okay I'll look at it after this
thank you
[Music]
all right let's see
won't you tend to my womb
I got a Dodge was Unstoppable
man
stay behind me please
[Music]
okay okay okay okay here we go
I'm probably about to get stomped out
the door
but it's okay
[Music]
am I faster than him
I want his his unblockables because it
seems like that is the best way to
stagger people in this game
okay so he's got AOE attack
okay don't get hit by that again
[Music]
yeah we're not getting hit by that again
does he not have AOE
the little red ones
he might not have right attacks
I wish he didn't have that move
I'm sure
do you just have to live for a certain
amount of time
oh he does have a unblockable okay
[Music]
I should hit him a couple times there
good opportunity
come on
and you're dead
okay okay okay
starting to learn a little bit like good
times of opening is when he does a
little attack he hits it straight down
like those are the good opportunities to
hit him
all right someone says something about
spells uh wizard spells learn wizard
spells okay so I can learn one of each
increase automatic recovery during low
spirit and decrease the amount of
depletion during High Spirit
this seems useful
let's try that
can I even learn the other stuff
yeah so you can learn the first one no
matter what
oh no you can't you need level two
oh so you can learn the one on
the right side it looks
let's poison him
that sounds very useful
all right
so
all right let's try this
all right
[Music]
too much combat I like more gameplay
than anything to be honest with him
[Music]
come on
okay I'm getting better with that
[Music]
oh
not looking at the chat I see it though
yes
oh
how'd you guys feel about that perfect
all right so let's see
I got hit a little bit there
a little bit there it's fine though oh
my God I'm completely messing up man oh
yeah it's like a greedy Let's help it
too
uh what's he doing now
that's unfair
well the opportunity to present itself
that reach is ridiculous
hey man
running out of health potions
please do that Unstoppable
oh he did an Unstoppable on top of it
unstoppable that's unfair
foreign
oh it's not looking good for me chat
what
what is this oh it's a little summon
things I remember this from the other
demo
foreign
oh okay maybe there's a third phase what
is going on
yeah
[Music]
every bit as strong as the rumors say
man there's seriously a third phase
really
um what did he just snatch
oh there's not a third phase he I I Auto
lost I lost
I lost off screen off combat that's fine
I'm cool with losing to the AI in a
cinematic cut scene but I'd be damned if
I lose in real life okay they they took
the control out of my hand you can't
blame me for that I'd have thought that
old man it would have been over I'd have
got him up out of there it was them who
decided that I wasn't gonna win that
fight and that that that's just how it
is
this world is steep shut up
it needs one like you to bring peace
well you got killed anyway well maybe
he's not dead it looked like they
snatched something from him
I don't know I'm not watching these
cutscenes or anything until the actual
game comes out
all right so I got armor
cleaner in the final game I carrying
over the state or to the road version it
came with deliveries
okay
yeah let's put on his stuff
thank you
okay hold up
I was put up Health again
I like having Health more than anything
feel like I'm a little slower
there we go
oh God okay I take you all along that oh
cutscene never mind
on God do it
apparently someone's here oh I gotta
can't lead before someone's with me
my name is Joe Yoon what's up jao Yang
the yellow turbans have control of Mount
dongshan
you don't look short of confidence but
surely it would be reassuring to have an
ally at your side
all right let's see here
all right
okay
I don't normally stick with big things
like this but I'm willing to try
to get careless
oh
[Music]
I'm hurt
oh looks like there's a flag up there
let me go for that flag
I wonder if I could just run through the
whole map
okay I got you they were so starch they
couldn't possibly have fun
oh
recognition
it's pretty strong I'll admit it on that
what is these things
oh it looks like it increased my thing
Elemental surprise
oh God
can we win
yeah get out of here with that nonsense
all right we're good there
got this
oh the dog
the dog might be too fast for me
oh yeah but if I hit him one time it's a
wrap
oh God
that was terrifying
what's this down here
okay
we're not fighting them let's just go to
the to whatever this area is
oh it's another boss already
oh he does damage
[Music]
wow
that dude that dude messed me up I'm not
gonna lie
oh the morale thing I don't know what
morale he was he's probably way higher
than me wasn't he
what's mine
a five
oh these are seven okay
I need to get mine up
oh that that yeah there we go hold up
gotcha
oh
yeah get dealt with
oh it's this way
oh
what's over here
let's consider falling back
15.
12.
yeah let's not take them on
don't want to die
we go
I bet you there's weapons and stuff in
these houses
gotcha there we go let's get that
um
I'm level six right now
[Music]
oh God
there we go
we gotta find more of those
flag thing oh there's one right there
all right
foreign
[Music]
oh I like that Stomps
all right let's do this
got iron sword
so we're eight now
oh we unlock something called
reinforcements I assume
to call people to help us baby
maybe yeah AI is most likely
oh God it's that log thing
there we go
I like this thing man
I like this hammer
let's level up a little bit and go try
to fight him again
I should probably level up more than
just my health
what is that
okay
all right let's just go
foreign
I do want the iron sword in case I need
something
all right let's try this dude again
this time we're about to I mean we're
about to hit nine so
I mean 10. Mazda just hit it real quick
all right now we're 10. we should be the
same level as the boss now
because he was twice as strong as us
now it's a it it's it's an equal
Battlefield
I like that red mode
[Music]
I feel like I'm playing um
Monster Hunter right now
[Music]
okay
oh here's that move oh I got it
let's hit him
oh
just about half his health
[Music]
got it
come on hit him hit him
oh God
[Music]
yeah I knew that was hitting me
it was so close
dead
oh we got some more armor
[Music]
not too bad so far
I hope it reviews good too
oh another spirit I guess
We're Not Gonna spoil any of the story
guys
okay I had not expected demons to be
among them this could become even more
difficult
nonetheless we will not back down all
right so we level 10
We're Not Gonna Take on those one people
yet because they were level 15.
yeah those pairs are important man
see
the county office
okay he wasn't so hard to knock out
you know what I want something a little
faster
you sound a little faster
for these small dudes
ah let's look for those flags those
flags are very important it seems
people are Level 14. I'm sure
I'm sure it will serve you well
a crystal vein what is a crystal vein
[Music]
oh you can use and okay
shoes
oh god what the hell
where did he come from
the dude came out of nowhere
yeah yeah
let's get that out of here
now let's find that dude
carries where he is he was over here
oh there he is
thank you
there we go
wow
I'm getting like like
surprise hit for like in front of me or
behind me
let's try that again
you miss me with that stuff
it's crazy help
quick this dude can get this big thing
out
come on
how many people's up there
all right all right
can I sneak up on him somehow
oh no there's no sneaking up on him
I'm not fighting two people
let's get rid of this dude
yeah you're falling
thank you
all right hold up
can I pick him up without getting seen
there we go I can
thank you get up here don't go fight
that dude
actually he's facing the other way
can I sneak up on him
he hits me like one time it's a wrap
fast oh
there we go
yeah sounds are pretty good in this game
things are level 18.
there we go
we still got it
let's go fight that dude that's over on
that end
why is he yellow
oh there's people up here
goodness
oh what level 16.
[Music]
I don't think that level 16 is dead no
he is
all right we good
um
I don't know maybe if
I need like kids move oh
17. okay
should I just go try to fight the the
boss
yeah let's just go try and fight the
I don't know where he is
let's see here
and I kind of want to be light to a
point
that's too heavy
do you feel you want to get it
is this the ball I'll soon see why
just make sure that you are ready you
act like you know more than I do
laughs
oh God what is this
okay
wow that dude killed me almost instantly
that was crazy
that that morale thing is important you
really gotta look at that if that
morale's too low the amount of damage
they do to you is like crazy
foreign
we've already went that way
what's up fawns
fighting Cowboys isn't that the reviewer
oh what's this it's that room isn't it
come on in here dude
I guess I'm fighting by myself
yeah at least you tried
the reach on this thing is crazy
so it seems like the morale
is the level like the damage that they
do if
um you see how like let's look at this
dude he's got 12 I got 14. so he's gonna
naturally do more damage but it seems
like the bigger difference that number
is the worst is on you
nice for years to join us
how do I get in there
all right so
start with a secret attack
that didn't do nothing
let's do what I did last time
yeah yeah yeah
oh we beat him
I like that Earth One
these things like these little banners
bring that up it looks like c14 now it's
a 17.
but it looks like it
someone in the chat said that that goes
up if you're dead
so if I die I come back as a 17.
oh
I think this is where I just came from
it yeah it is
pretty good um
good system
what's this way
oh it looks like another way there yeah
we don't got to go that way though Chad
we go this way
um
we want to go this way
climb up here because we never went down
this thing over here
yeah I kind of figured that looked like
they were just leading to the same place
what's up Mystic
is this like Neo it got a little bit of
a fiddler a familiar
Phil as Neo but I wouldn't say it's Neo
yeah I would say Neo and sicaro like
together
would be a better analogy for this game
I will say that
all right let's try this again chat
now we're level 20.
he's hit him twice
move
d
I'm gonna switch because I want
something quicker
there we go oh
bam
all right so so far so good
so a little fire now
[Music]
yeah see I'm able to get in and out
quicker this way
yeah he's so easy to read
baby
hold that
here have another one
have another one
oh
there you go
how
how do you go back up to 20.
there you go
home diet
he's getting burnt
oh
he's just he's he's just rotating over
and over again now
let me go and take a post to just be on
the safe side
yeah
God hit him
music
oh so now you're just gonna keep doing
that over and over again
and this is at least says Behavior
changes a little bit here you go I know
you like that
[Music]
foreign
I wish you would do an unblockable
one that I know I don't want him doing
some new moving kill me one egg that'd
be a disaster
come on just doing a red move man
foreign
you could do a red move
oh he's down I mean he was useless
anyway
here
oh
with this Victory we move a step closer
to peace
you guys know how it is man
I think that's enough
let me switch back
I don't want to play too much of the
game because then I feel like I'm not
really getting nothing out of it if that
makes sense to you guys
uh so far I would say
it's it's it's Unique
I think that's fair unique
how do you guys feel
oh the progress transfer is over that's
cool
maybe I should have stayed in there then
so
I think
my question with that game is Just
how well
how well is everything going to to fill
with all these new mechanics they've put
in in this
you know I will say that the demo they
gave us a couple months ago they they
took a lot of good criticism I will say
that uh you know that's why we need to
see more demos it's not I get it
releasing demos hurts your product in
the long run but I do feel like you
could take feedback and make a better
product in general before the actual
game comes out
foreign
if that makes sense to you guys
so far so good I really liked it though
I really liked it
want to see how Co-op is
uh
I assume it's like something like uh
the co-op that we we we're used to
I assume that
I hope it's better than how they do in
Dark Souls or you have to put like
symbols down and stuff I hope it's not
that
give me a competent Co-op experience
that's what I want
so
now that we've played the demo
chat put in that put in that comment
section what do you think this game is
going to rate
put it put down there man what do you
guys think this is gonna get in terms of
Metacritic wise I say 83 to 85.
I would say around there
I feel very comfortable around that area
eight eights for sure
I could totally see eight
's work pretty good
I don't think we have anything to worry
about it's pretty good
low nines I'd be very surprised if it
got it in the nines I'd be very happy
too
you know I think team ninja is a very
prominent studio and I actually think
that
Microsoft has like a really good you
know Vibe when it comes to the Ninja
Gaiden series
because of everything that's going on
with them uh you know a lot of people
when they think of ninja guy and they
think of Xbox and I feel like Microsoft
really needs to buy team ninja and buy
the Ninja Gaiden franchise and have them
work on them because if there's anything
Microsoft always misses out on it's like
the a lot of like from software projects
who owns
Ninja Gaiden
because I don't know who owns that uh
Tecmo
yeah so I mean it could work out they
can get their hands on that uh I I think
I think team ninja has proven that they
can make good games with a little bit of
guidance and some you know maybe better
budgeting I think we can get some really
solid experiences on the Xbox brand
because they I think you know they don't
need that I think they they have
established a pretty good Western RPG
obviously it's looking like you know we
might not get
the uh Boulder Gate 3 at least that
launch currently right now uh so you
know that that's something that's very
disappointing especially I was a huge
fan of divinity you know Divinity
original sin great game you guys saw
it's one of the last games I played yeah
I want those games to do more and I
think that's one of the frustrations I
have it's like I I truly and honestly
would want to see you know that type of
playing style with Ninja Gaiden like
imagine wulong's Ninja uh like it's a
little style but you know tweaked a
little bit because I think Ninja Gaiden
probably be a little bit more to do with
stealth wise but I do want to think it
needs to be a
an option between
stealth
and fighting you know I don't want it to
be one of those things where they
shoehorn and make you use fighting
styles or they shoehorn and make you
do the the uh the stealth way I want it
to truly be like a mixed thing where you
feel comfortable if you want to play
either way or you know a mixture where
you know you try to stealth kind of like
those old Sam Fisher you know Tom Clancy
games uh where you do attempt to go in
there as a stealth-like uh mindset and
then when stuff hits the fan you just
start start going crazy on stuff man I
think I think that that would be really
good I think especially if XBox could uh
get that as a timed exclusive or a
full-blown exclusive because I
personally feel like Game Pass is good
but they they need to do more
exclusivities because uh Sony has no
problem uh ex getting these
exclusivities they have no problem doing
it so I think Microsoft needs to be a
little bit more aggressive in that area
you know you don't have to get
everything that comes in the game pass
as a timed exclusive you can still do
your your game pass deals it's just you
know some games like woo long it would
have been a lot it would have hit way
better if this was a timed exclusive or
a full-blown exclusive and I feel like
Microsoft you know just dabble a little
bit more into that that vein I know that
they've been really focusing their own
stuff that's why I suggest you know by
team ninja team ninja are very prominent
make very fast-paced games
get you that Ninja Gaiden franchise and
I think you can go a long way with it
that's just my opinion on the matter
all right but that that's pretty much
the stream guys I appreciate you all
coming in here man you know I'm going to
be doing a lot of content on my channel
and streaming on Twitch you know I love
streaming but I still love making
content and I've been so focused on the
IOP stuff that I haven't had the chance
to really sit down and focus on making
videos for my personal YouTube channel
but I think I'm going to really take the
time and
make sure that I can do a little bit of
both because I I need my own personal
Outlet I do but I appreciate you ever
coming through until next time this is
attic I'm out of here peace see you
Sunday